are politicians better at making
decisions on what to do with our money
or are we
um I mean I guess unlike uh in a broad
way I would say if we're going to look
at the biggest chunk of money in the
government to make this assessment right
1.7 trillion dollars Social Security
and we can compare it to the one sort of
like comparable thing in the private in
the private sector and that's a 401k
I would have to say I mean just based
upon your the way you set up this
question that obviously the government
because Social Security
has been the single most effective
program that we have in this country it
has kept uh two-thirds of our senior
citizens out of poverty as a social
insurance program
401ks have been a disaster
foreign
[Music]